hands von Spakovsky is a former member
the Federal Election Commission he's a
senior legal fellow with the Heritage
Foundation in Washington he joins us
thanks for coming on sure so if it turns
out that the Obama campaign received
this data that would be an in-kind
contribution correct it is because it's
very valuable data and in fact the
former media director for the Obama
campaign said that Facebook actually
came to their offices and said well we
don't normally give this data out but
we're gonna let you have it because we
favor your campaign that turns it into
potentially an illegal corporate
contribution how would that not be
illegal
how would that not be a crime well you
know if if they made this data available
to anybody who wants it well then of
course any campaign could get it but the
fact that they specifically had rules
against this does make it an in-kind
contribution contrast this with what
they did with Cambridge analytic
remember Cambridge analytical when they
found out about this they went to
Cambridge analytical and said you need
to destroy this data you're not supposed
to have it and that tells you that
in the one case they let the campaign
have it in another case they were saying
well no you're not supposed to have this
data so Facebook but also Google and
Twitter and Apple the big tech companies
can easily throw an election and we
wouldn't know it and so we should be
terrified of this I don't think we're
terrified enough but what is the US
Congress what are the appropriate
agencies in the executive branch doing
to make sure that these huge companies
who have more power than any companies
have ever had in human history our
remaining transparent I mean we're
certain this is not happening what are
they doing to reassure us of that well
for example in in the case of the Obama
campaign potentially getting a corporate
contribution which is illegal that ought
to be investigated by the Federal
Election Commission where I used to be a
commissioner because it's a potential
violation the law no idea whether they
are going to open up investigation
potentially also the US Justice
Department could investigate it because
if it wasn't intentional and knowing
violation of the law that takes it from
being a civil violation to a criminal
violation so both of those federal
agencies have potential jurisdiction
over this so
no one has said at any of those agencies
if they're gonna open up an
investigation that's what they ought to
do though yeah oh yeah well if you have
lunch none of your friends encourage
them
yeah well that thank you very much